Starting today with a warning.
And I think this is an important one.
And this is a warning to my fellow do something
leftists.
You know, Trump talks about the do nothing
left.
I care about the do something left.
I've always cared about getting things done.
And the warning is as follows.
Do not allow the right and in particular the
Trumpy and right to make the next three and
a half months up until the presidential election
about these cultural war topics that they're
increasingly trying to use to distract from
the policy failures of this administration
and to distract from the governance failures
of this administration.
Now, I'm including in this the Trump administration
itself.
Trump lists, but also the Republicans who
maybe they're not vocally pro Trump, but they've
stood aside and allowed Donald Trump to do
essentially whatever he wants.
They've rubber stamped the judges.
And to really understand this, we've got to
do a little bit of homework.
So first of all, when we talk about culture
war, we're talking about cultural conflict.
We're not talking about policy battles.
Right.
We're talking about a value.
A battle over whose values are going to reign
supreme.
And these are also often these culture war
battles.
They're often over issues where there's more
disagreement than on policy.
So on policy, we see on health care, on abortion,
the country is nowhere near united.
But there is much more support.
On one side, there's much less division as
far as 50 50 division than we've seen in a
long time.
So I should remind you, there's a lot of right
wingers and even so-called enlightened centrists
who claim the left is waging a culture war
and the right is just desperate to get a word
in edgewise or something like that.
That has never been less true than it is now.
The right is fomenting a culture war specifically
because they believe it will help them win
in November because they can't justify their
reelections in any other way because they
failed.
So let's take the abortion example for a moment.
For a longtime abortion was a hot button cultural
war issue.
And over time, American opinion about abortion
has become more and more on the side of in
most cases, abortion should be legal.
That makes abortion less of an ideal issue
with which to wage a culture war.
Now, among evangelical conservative circles
and in religious groups, being against abortion
is still a pretty good way to raise money
for your campaign.
But abortion has become a less efficient way
to polarize people to your advantage.
Right now, everything we're seeing when it
comes to sports team names, Confederate flags,
Confederate monuments, protesters being peaceful
versus violent, and to what degree is it one
or the other?
And to what degree do we need to give police
deference?
These are all fomenting a culture war which
does not favor the left in this election cycle.
Even Corona virus has actually become a cultural
war issue.
Specifically, when it comes to masks as a
proxy for this ideology of freedom and liberty.
And don't tread on me.
There is actually a debate to be had over,
for example, which statues should come up,
should come down, and which statues should
stay up, which names should be cleansed from
history and which should be allowed to stand
reasonable.
People can disagree about, you know, where
is the line between taking down a statue or
what constitutes an offensive sports team
name.
But the problem is that for the next three
and a half months, it is a complete distraction
from policy and which policy platform we are
voting for.
Nobody gets health care.
If you're George Washington, statue stays
up, but the Robert E. Lee statue comes down.
Reasonable people can disagree, but that doesn't
get anybody health care.
The Washington Redskins changing their name
does nothing to improve education in any way,
but it allows the right wing to continue parroting
this idea of WOAK leftist mobs spreading cancel
culture.
They are losing like they've never lost before
on policy and governance, with the exception
of getting a bunch of judges confirmed.
And that also doesn't get enough attention.
While we're arguing about Confederate flags
now, I've played clips, clips for you over
the last few days, weeks where Donald Trump
has been asked about his biggest first term
accomplishments and his second term agenda,
and he can barely answer those questions.
That alone should disqualify Trump from a
second term, but that gets less attention
when they can make this about.
We're fighting a culture of Marxism, which,
of course, doesn't exist or cancel culture
or whatever they want to talk about.
Now, where this gets difficult is that corporate
media plays into this.
Corporate media will stage these debates with
people with particularly.
Rheem positions on these issues.
Person A says keep every Confederate statue,
person B says take down every statue, including
George Washington, because he owns slaves.
And it is wasted time.
It's wasted time, number one, because most
people don't hold such extreme views.
Like most Americans, I think actually would
be pretty reasonable.
And they'd say, well, there's a difference
between someone known for fighting to keep
slavery in this country or else they will
leave the union vs..
George Washington is really known for other
things, including saying we need a president,
not a king, etc. and slavery was a sign of
the times.
It doesn't excuse slavery, but most people
would understand the difference there.
So the debates and media are set up with people
with the most extreme views, and it only serves
to distract from the historic failures we've
seen from the current administration on corona
virus, on foreign policy, on education, on
trade, on health care, etc.
They win when the conversation is about flags
and statues because it hides that they face
planted on every important issue for the last
three and a half years.
So what we need to do is keep the focus on
policy from now until November 3rd. Trump's
polling has imploded for three major reasons.
His handling of coronavirus, his handling
of the economy in the context of coronavirus
relative to other countries, and his insane
reactions, his authoritarian reactions to
the George Floyd protests.
He's failed to deliver on just about every
campaign promise.
The United States is a global laughingstock.
Those are the issues we should talk about,
the failures there and Joe Biden as an alternative
and put aside these cultural issues because
they benefit from the discussion being about
flags and statues rather than about their
policy failures.